Speaker 1: This you are not going to believe
or maybe you are.
And maybe that's the problem, that it's so
predictable Republicans are now really, really
concerned about.
Wait for it discrimination now you might say.
Well, discrimination against too is it?
They now care about discrimination against
racial minorities, which they previously said
doesn't happen.
Nope, that's not it.
Does the right now care about discrimination
against the poor?
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
They're still OK criminalizing poverty in
many cities and states.
Are they now worried about discrimination
against women?
No antisemitism.
Are they ready to finally say we can't have?
No, it's not that either.
Republicans are now really concerned about
discrimination against unvaccinated people
choosing not to get vaccinated against the
covid virus.
We are now seeing state Republican lawmakers
across the country propose and advocate for
new bills, one of which is already law which
would protect unvaccinated people in the way
that people are already protected based on
race, gender and religion, and even going
beyond the way many states protect folks on
the basis of sexual orientation or gender
identity.
Think about that.
It is still legal to discriminate against
people based on sexual orientation, real or
perceived gender identity, real or perceived
in more than 20 states.
You can fire people or say you can't do business
at my store based on sexual orientation and
gender identity in more than 20 states.
But suddenly, Republicans want to protect
anti Vaxevanis in the same way that race and
religion are protected.
What a country we live in.
The way these bills would work if they become
law and one of them has become law, is that
they would ban businesses from saying, if
you want to work here in person, you've got
to be vaccinated.
Businesses would be banned from doing that
if these bills become law or businesses wouldn't
be allowed to say you have to be vaccinated
to be a customer of our business.
We've already seen vaccinated and unvaccinated
sections at some sporting venues, sporting
event facilities.
We've already seen Republicans call vaccination
programs and masks like Naziism, like apartheid,
like the Holocaust.
And now they're saying treat being against
the vaccine, just like we treat being black
or being Christian under the law.
Now, consider something particularly absurd
about this.
One of the reasons that Republicans often
don't want sexual orientation protected in
the same way that race is protected or religion
is protected is they say, well, sexual orientation
is a choice.
We don't protect just choices that people
make or everybody straight.
Some people choose to live a gay life.
Now, this is, of course, not true.
It's not true.
But if you were to grant that to them and
say, OK, your principle is you only want to
protect inherent traits and you don't consider
sexual orientation inherent, you're of the
mindset that people choose their sexual orientation.
All right, being vaccinated is a choice.
Being vaccinated is unquestionably something
you can control, you can't control whether
you're black, white or Asian, you can't control
whether you have a disability, you can't control
your age.
You can't control the country you were born
in.
Vaccination is a choice and you can control
it.
And it's Republicans who have been saying
we don't protect things that are choices under
the law.
Now, I would go even further because I've
said before, there are good arguments that
religion should not be protected as a class
because it's a choice.
Now, there are people who will say, well,
kinda I mean, you're brought up in a religion.
So it's not totally like I mean, yeah, you
can leave the religion, but you're kind of
born into it because your family's religion
is what's at least initially passed on to
you.
But or you might say, well, yeah, the thing
about religion, even though it's a choice,
is the country is really was based on the
concept of religious freedom, either to be
whatever religion you want or not to be any.
And so there's something special about religion
in terms of the founding of the country and
thus it should be protected.
However, you assess religion and it being
a choice, vaccination is unquestionably more
of a choice.
So why should it be protected?
And these are the same folks who say businesses
shouldn't be regulated, let them do what they
want, except if what they want is to say,
hey, if you choose not to get a vaccine, you
can't work here or maybe you can't shop here.
Oh, no, no, that's too much.
All of a sudden for these very same Republicans,
we need to ban that.
And by banning that, what we're saying is
impose more regulation on businesses.
They say they're against business regulation.
This is very heavy handed business regulation.
So it's a total hypocrisy.
It's another double standard.
But where it is consistent, it's that it's
another way for Republicans to play the victim.
They are the victims as told by their imaginary
narratives.
And the reality is that discriminating against
people based on actions
Speaker 3: is
Speaker 1: how things should go in most cases.
And what I mean by that is when people behave
in a way that's anti-social or dangerous to
public health or whatever, shouldn't businesses
be able to say we will sanction those individuals
not because of who they are, but because of
what they've chosen to do?
And one such sanctioning is if you're not
vaccinated, you can't shop here.
You can't work here because you're a risk
to the people that are here.
Basically, the principle that actually is
at play is if it affects them, it's discrimination
as they see it.
And then you need regulation to stop it.
Truly vile people.
And while fortunately at the federal level,
this anti vaccine crusade isn't getting much
oxygen, they are having some success at the
state level.
One of these bills has already become law.
And we have to really be on guard for it because
they are pushing hard and they already have
one victory.
It's horrible, horrible stuff.
The world sees this and they say, sirs, what
are you doing?
What are you doing?
And I don't have the answer.
I'm as embarrassed by it as many around the
world are.